hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to I see a player there
my name just went over a player
oh don't find me I saw something there
was something over there there was a
player did I shoot him should I fill it
full of bullets I don't know if he sees
me or not have a gun I'll show you you
Buzzard where'd he go
no no
okay
where is he
where'd he go he was here now he's gone
I think he might have been shooting
those two things over yonder way not
even gonna give him the chance I'm not
gonna give him the chance this is what
it comes down to ah okay oh no oh I'm so
dead this hang on oh don't kill me
oh no Gilly Oh kill me come on
give me all your my bandages six come on
okay come up use him up please him up
use him up musn't hide cuz that other
player might be bad those two different
players there I think I killed the one
player pretty sure pretty sure he's dead
the other player might come back cuz he
heard the gunshots
oh god I'm overloading my mic so much on
this one cuz they just i randomly yell
and oh I apologize if the audio quality
is not what it usually is oh I'm so I
don't do well with these situations okay
yeah he's dead cuz they're all his good
he's on the ground okay okay
look okay okay got an assault rifle look
okay
all right
let me grab that got this other gun I'm
gonna I didn't like that machete thing
gonna go prone when I go back actually
my hidey-hole no one can find me oh oh I
don't feel good about the things I've
done but at least I am Alive for now oh
okay
what is that he had a lot of guns my
hands are shaking guys hey okay hey I
got some ammo in this one
that's silence does that what this means
probably good gonna have let me unload
this one but I can uh a nine-millimeter
ammo yeah
the 9-millimeter and that way let me
just look at this reload this oh my
hands are shaking guys I don't do well
in stressful situations like this Oh
whoo all right I need to take calm
breath
ah okay ah all right
I'm also having two eaten today so I've
got like the sugar shakes then those
aren't doing too well for me so I've got
a mo
I've got guns I need to get out of this
place because apparently this is a hot
spot for players apparently I'm just
gonna try is there was there another way
out of the stock over and we're kind of
in a dead-end because I might be I've
got a lot of goods I want to get out of
here ah this is a dead end
okay I'm gonna crawl to where I killed
the guy and then go right my hands are
seriously like tingling like you
wouldn't believe
I'm gonna oh I've never had a game
affect me like this I am very very very
much wanting to be survival I'm gonna
quit my not mine the dead guy's gun here
just set up an ambush for him but that
was the brakes I guess I don't even
think it says who kills cat damn it okay
okay I don't even think it says like who
kills who I think it's like just thing
okay oh wait no no no there's more ammo
there I didn't see that nine-millimeter
ammo good good good good good
I'm not going well because my health is
kind of low I could be killed like with
one shot I just got to be SuperDuper
careful here like SuperDuper careful
okay there's an enemy over there I go
the other way oh I gotta be still
carefully I'm out in the open I'm so out
in the open
oh I'm still open
I'm not gonna sprint if you want me to
sprint you go to help was it do you want
me to it's doing that thing I was here
before they just wanted me to examine
something like architecture or whatever
so far so good that's where I went that
over that wall is death nether scourge
okay does that even mean that like an
event that players go to to try to close
it or or something like that or that's
where there's a lot of zom zoms assuming
I walked right into that before then
again I might be wrong
I've been wrong numerous times okay
I'm just gonna keep heading east and
north to try to make it through the
outskirts of the map that way I can try
to circumvent um any unwanted encounters
if you know what I mean I don't want to
have to kill people but I'm pretty much
gonna shoot anyone on sight at this
point
I'm gonna try to hide in the nooks and
crannies so that I'm not out in the open
I don't even have anything to say right
now I'm I thought I saw something this
grasp moving across the screen I'm just
and that guy is a dead guy I'm just I'm
a little stressed uh stressed if you
know what I mean
a little stressed I'm gonna get up high
what I'm gonna do what okay those thumb
blown in the window nothing I need to
worry about right right get a bathroom
is this what crouched to go into that
bathroom this weird that's weird that's
weird
I need to work on the interior design in
this game cuz that's weird
hey what there's an enemy over there no
one no gunshots I hear I'm gonna assume
that standing on a rooftop is also a bad
idea because someone spawned me from a
mile away
Hey
okay it's a gas station over there it's
practically glowing I don't know how
there's still power in a zombie
apocalypse but I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna criticize that because I'm here
you okay so that a safe zone or
something that say outpost over there so
there's an outpost over there we could
sell stuff that's also where players
might be oh I'm afraid to move I have
good stuff that I stole but I have but I
stole it but I killed someone in cold
blood and stole it but I have it I don't
want to lose it
oh where do I go what do we do uh oh
he's too close for comfort
hello it what do it what do I do I'm
frozen what okay I'll just keep going
this way
oh hi rats can I eat you I need to drink
this water oh not that not that
hey drink the water doing good I feel so
much better what is that oh I actually
found a supply that I didn't merge
murder to someone for I don't actually
need that I really don't need that ah no
oh I need to use my first-aid kit
hey I'm full health okay oh you bastard
what happened I fell through that fire
escape oh okay
till the railyards are up there I don't
know if there's actually gonna be
anything good I'm gonna try to get to
this gas station it yeah oh god no no
oh god dammit dammit dammit why why why
why why why why why yeah I think he
appeared through the wall or something
Oh God
good this is silence cuz that guy did
not hear anything I don't think okay
alright that was stupid that shouldn't
happen again
okay alright
once again hold playthrough same face
just oh no oh no don't come near me
don't do anything I don't wanna do
anything just don't do nothing oh oh I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die huh guess all
that this is this is a beacon this is a
trap this is a beacon for other players
to go to and die or kill me they're
gonna kill me but I just got to kill
them first what I got to do what I'm
gonna do don't kill me don't kill me
don't kill me don't kill me I'll kill
you first
don't kill me what is that what is that
what is that what is that what is it
going I can't pick it up I don't care I
don't want it I don't want that I want
to go that's good that's good
I went into gas station I went out I
went anyone out I did something
I did something valuable oh oh don't go
okay okay don't go don't back
oh no you don't want to eat it
oh no this my god
okay okay with that I'm gonna level up
character guns okay all right what does
that do
steady aim oh that doesn't help me I
should have done survival or something
cuz ah my survival skills are not very
good okay let's go into this industrial
park area oh okay
did I mention that I don't like games
like this I was having fun before but
then it got real it got real real it got
really really real mana oh I just know a
player's gonna come oh oh oh I don't
want to cross this beep oh oh oh I don't
want to crusty someone's gonna shoot me
someone's gonna shoot me someone's gonna
shoot me someone's gonna shoot me
someone saw me that was coming for me
I'll kill you first oh oh oh I saw
something in that window ah
no I saw something that time come on
down that roof come on down that roof
look okay all right I feel like Kronk
when he was delivering the Emperor to
his death no no no no no no no no no no
no no no where am i I'm going nowhere
oh I'm going nowhere nowhere fast I'm
going nowhere man
oh okay something's gonna happen been
too quiet oh I'm on the open amount the
orbit is on the open I'm out in the open
someone's gonna shoot me oh if the
developers of the game ever seen is this
for my sanity can you like give me like
a mask with a big moustache on it big
pink mustache
I'd like that make me feel right at home
and then maybe I wouldn't be so stressed
okay ha slashing how I'm like so on edge
I'm on edge I'm dos tres DOS dressed
something's gotta give something's gonna
happen what though oh no no you why
aren't you dying why does this not do
nearly enough damage as it's supposed to
snitty gun
oh it's just openness I got across the
river at some point but I really don't
want to what's over here let me see
what's over here first I'm sort of
convenience store why is there still
power oh man there's lost up here I
don't want the baseball bat
pain pain pills I'll do 9-millimeter
ammo perfect for my other gun a crowbar
that could be incredibly useful and let
me equip that and drop this kitchen
knife okay good good good good
cigarettes I'll sell those chewing gum I
can sell that bandage is always good
okay okay oh I've got so many valuables
oh I'm so rich I'm so rich everybody on
the server come kill markiplier he's got
so much stuff just a walking bag of
goodies like a pinata you hit him and
good stuff comes out no not like that
don't be weird oh don't be weird okay
crossing the bridge crossing the bridge
I shouldn't be this nervous I want to go
back to when I was running through this
world all aloof and fun carefree happy
haha hahaha oh it's nothing but open oh
it's nothing but open whoa is that it's
not someone no I lied to myself nothing
but open nothing but open I'm gonna go
up in this building and I'm gonna stay
there so that I can actually not lose
all my stuff and save this for next time
because I'm making a lot of progress I
don't want to lose it I made a lot of
progress I do not want to lose it Owen
go please don't let there be if there's
someone like at the top of this tower
and I just happened to run into him and
he shoots me in the face let me let my
why is my sprint bar not recovering
there it goes there goes dude it's like
on a timer I don't know okay get this
his top Oh God messages I don't know
what those mean but another surge ended
all right okay good you see the holes
down from here okay good I'm gonna lay
down now
and not have a heart attack okay so I'm
just gonna stay here my hands are
shaking my heart's pounding I'm dying I
can take the can't you I can't deal with
this so anyway oh man thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
hey it was like oh man
it's got a buddy because it looked like
have you ever guys wear the badge now
and thankfully brokers
anymore but I can't get out of this
place right what are you
don't walk or you will die okay